aquí en la can academy queremos empezar
un nuevo proyecto de software y para eso
necesitamos ver cuántos programadores
queremos contratar queremos ver cuál es
la cantidad óptima de programadores
saleh para esto vamos a trabajar en esta
hoja de cálculo de acá aquí no voy a
poder dibujar pero voy a poder teclear
saleh y entonces esto nos va a ayudar
pues saber cómo podemos utilizar una
hoja de cálculo para esto pero además
para poder entender más o menos cómo se
optimiza pues un proyecto de esta
naturaleza bueno vamos a empezar aquí
hasta la izquierda con el número de
programadores que puede ir desde 0 hasta
10 luego vamos a ver aquí líneas de
código por mes ok entonces esto es
cuántas líneas de código pueden escribir
la cantidad correspondiente de
programadores cinco programadores
escribirían 10.600 líneas de código esta
información se puede obtener no se
promediando los programadores de la
industria o preguntándole a las empresas
y así a lo mejor líneas de código por
mes no es la mejor medida
digo pueden ser líneas muy buenas o
líneas muy malas de código pero es una
de medir bueno entonces vamos a empezar
llenando la tabla comenzando por los
costos fijos los costos fijos son todos
esos costos que no importa cuántos
programadores tengamos siguen siendo
iguales es decir pueden ser esos costos
por ejemplo la renta de la oficina o
pagarle a un coordinador que esté
supervisando a los programadores o la
limpieza de la oficina vaya son costos
que no dependen de la cantidad de
programadores que tengamos sino del
hecho de que queremos empezar este
proyecto
entonces supongamos que vamos a pagarle
100 mil pesos de salario al supervisor
de los programadores y que vamos a pagar
otros 50 mil pesos de renta y limpieza
entonces le voy a poner 150 mil pesos
aquí también serían 150 mil pesos porque
son costos fijos y podría seguir
escribiendo pero como es con hoja de
cálculo puede utilizar este cuadrito de
acá seleccionó las dos celdas y
utilizando este cuadrito de acá y
moviéndome hacia abajo puedo llenar toda
esa columna
ahora vamos a pasar a los costos
variables los costos variables y
dependen de la cantidad de programadores
y pueden ser pues el salario de los
programadores o su seguro de vida que
tenemos que contratar les o a lo mejor
podría ser la cantidad de galletas que
se comen en la cafetería entonces estos
costos de casi dependen de cuántos
programadores tenemos y no se pensemos
que ya contemplando todo eso es 100 mil
pesos por programador aquí le tendría
que poner cero pero en vez de ponerle
cero voy a poner una fórmula para
empezar a usar esto de las hojas este de
cálculo entonces aquí le voy a poner
igual
y fíjate le voy a poner que es 100 mil
100 mil es lo que nos cuesta cada
programador y lo voy a multiplicar por
ese asterisco es para multiplicar por la
cantidad de programadores por esta celda
de acá que es la celda 66 observa como
aquí puso la celda de 6 la elegí con las
flechitas y ya puso aquí que es la c6 le
voy a dar enter luego vamos al costo
total el costo total sería sumar estos
dos de acaba verdad los costos fijos con
los costos variables de modo similar voy
a poner una fórmula le voy a poner igual
elijo esta de acá que 150.000 las 6 y
luego le voy a sumar me voy a sumar esta
de acá los costos variables otra vez le
doy enter y ya aparece la suma de las
dos pero lo importante ahora es seguir
llenando esto verdad y una vez más con
este cuadrito podemos recorrer la
fórmula y observa esto está súper padre
verdad es como magia
aquí tenemos 700 mil que la fórmula es
100 mil por 13 entonces ya nos la puso
relativa del renglón que queremos el c3
es acá entonces lo multiplica por 7 muy
bien de modo similar puedo recorrer esta
de acá y ya nos queda el costo total
igual a la suma de los costos fijos con
los costos variables muy interesante
pero es mucho más interesante ver cuánto
cuestan las cosas en términos de pues de
lo que podemos programar verdad entonces
ahora vamos a empezar a llenar estas
columnas
vamos con los costos fijos promedio los
costos fijos promedio es de estos costos
fijos cuánto estamos pagando por cada
línea de código aquí cómo son 0 líneas
de código vamos a tener que dividir
150.000 entre 0 pero eso no está
definido entonces nos conviene calcular
los costos fijos promedio a partir del
segundo renglón entonces esto de acá es
igual a fíjate me voy a ir hacia la
izquierda digo le podrían poner 150 mil
porque siempre 150 mil pero a lo mejor
los costos fijos van a variar entonces
deja de ponerle igual a esta de acá que
es la 7 y eso lo voy a dividir entre la
cantidad de líneas de código por mes ok
le doy enter esto nos dice que son 37 50
eso ya es el precio por línea verdad en
términos de costos hijos del nuevo puedo
recorrer esto hacia abajo y observa aquí
más o menos ya podemos ver algunas
tendencias aquí podemos ver que va
bajando va bajando bajando lo cual tiene
sentido porque tenemos un cierto costo
fijo dividido entre más y más líneas de
código aquí pasa algo raro y ahorita
vamos a platicar acerca de eso ahora
vamos para acá a ver qué sucede
entonces aquí es costos variables
promedio vamos a ver y qué sería esto de
modo similar ahora es dividir los costos
variables entre la cantidad de líneas de
código por mes entonces vamos a ver cómo
lo pondríamos sería igual a esta celda
de acá de costos variables 17 dividido
otra vez entre la cantidad de líneas de
código por mes a ésta le damos enter son
25 pesos de costos variables por línea
de código
ok entonces desplazamos esto hacia abajo
y observa aquí pasa algo interesante
ahora los costos variables por medio no
van disminuyendo como en este caso sino
que van aumentando derecho a que
aumentan muchísimo verdad ya que se debe
esto pues mira vámonos a las líneas de
código por mes para ver pues cada
programador adicional cuántas líneas de
código adicionales nos da observa como
al pasar de cero a un programadores
tenemos cuatro mil líneas de código y
cuatro mil líneas de código entonces una
esperar ya que con dos programadores
fueran ocho mil pero son siete mil aquí
se escribirá esto y luego bajamos y
otras dos mil o sea luego en vez de
aumentar en 3.000 aumenta nada más en
2000 entonces como que parecen tener
menor productividad y no creas que es
porque se ponen a platicar digo eso
puede ser un factor pero es un factor
mínimo lo importante es que si tenemos
más programadores entonces se tienen que
poner de acuerdo en más cosas tienen que
coordinar su código y así y entonces una
mayor cantidad de programadores nos da
un beneficio adicional menor porque
tenemos que considerar esto desde la
coordinación y en realidad no sólo pasa
con con
amador es en muchas otras empresas
cuando tienes un proyecto y muchas
personas trabajando en el entonces no
puedes simplemente sumar toda la
utilidad que te genera cada una de las
personas porque hay más juntas hay más
coordinación hay pues más interrupciones
entonces en realidad va bajando la
eficiencia y de hecho acá si te das
cuenta tenemos menos líneas de código
por mes o sea al pasar al octavo
programador este de aquí nos genera
menos líneas de código que si tuviéramos
siete y entonces por ejemplo no es que
este tercer programador sea súper malo
sino que ahora en promedio van a nada
más programar o escribir tres mil líneas
bueno ese es más o menos la idea de por
qué estos costos variables promedio
suben tanto vale y porque aquí también
sube vamos al costo total promedio y el
costo total promedio pues podría sumar
estos dos eso sí funciona pero pero
vamos a hacerlo con formulita en otra
vez entonces vamos a ponerle que es el
costo total dividido entre la cantidad
de líneas de código por medio
le doy enter que da que 62 50 observa
que es la suma de estos dos y esto de
aquí podemos recorrerlo una vez más y
otra vez cosas interesantes verdad aquí
fíjate al pasar de cero a un
programadores pues pues el costo aumentó
a 60 y 2.5 bueno aquí hay más bien aquí
no teníamos nada más bien en un
programador es 62 pesos con 50 centavos
pero al pasar de 1 a 2 bajó el costo
total promedio eso está bueno porque
como que se repartieron los costos fijos
bien y aumentó bien la productividad
pero luego qué sucede se queda en 50 y
empieza a subir otra vez es por este
fenómeno de de ponerse de acuerdo aquí
de las juntas y de cosas por el estilo
bueno muy bien ese es el costo total
promedio ahora pasamos al costo marginal
promedio y este es un poquito más
complicado pero no tanto en esto
simplemente es cómo calcular en cuánto
nos cuesta un beneficio adicional
es decir vamos a pensar en cuánto nos
cuestan líneas de código adicionales
cómo le hacemos para calcular esto pues
hay que agarrar la intuición digo podría
poner la fórmula pero la voy a poner
pero vamos pensando porque funciona ok
le voy a poner que es igual
y aquí voy a abrir un paréntesis lo que
quiero ver es cuál es el costo adicional
entonces el costo adicional ahorita
pasando de 0 a un programadores es este
costo total al cual le tenemos que
restar el costo total anterior si por
eso agarro la celda de arriba entonces
cierro paréntesis
muy bien y eso lo tengo que dividir
entre la diferencia de líneas de código
o sea entre las líneas de código
adicionales es decir lo tendría que
dividir a paréntesis entre este de acá
que es de 7 - esto de acá arriba de 6
muy bien entonces le voy a dar enter nos
quedan 25 eso nos cuesta la línea
adicional y se llama promedio porque
todas estas de acá
todas estas 4 mil líneas nos costaron 25
pesos y cada una de ellas cada línea
adicional pero esto va cambiando aquí
abajo verdad por lo de la productividad
y los costos variables entonces vamos a
ver qué pasa con esto voy a recorrer la
línea la la formula hacia abajo ok
entonces mira va aumentando cada vez nos
cuesta más tener líneas adicionales de
código y aquí pasa algo exitoso verdad
dice que cuesta menos 500 y no es como
que nos paguen por tener líneas
adicionales de código más bien esto lo
que indica es que este octavo
programador ya hizo que tuviéramos menos
líneas de código entonces no nos está
saliendo negativo aquí porque porque nos
pagando sino porque tenemos menos líneas
de código
entonces esto es más o menos la
intuición detrás de todo lo que está
pasando aquí ya tenemos
los costos fijos variables y el total
pero es mejor sacarlos en promedio para
entender bien bien cuánto nos pagan qué
nos pasa con las líneas de código por
mes y finalmente el costo marginal
promedio nos dice cuánto nos cuesta cada
beneficio adicional va entonces bueno
espero que este vídeo haya servido más o
menos la idea era ver tres cosas número
uno ver esto de la intuición de los
distintos costos número dos ver cómo le
podemos hacer para hacer esto en una
hoja de cálculo y número tres pues
entender más o menos cómo funciona la
estructura de costos de una empresa